Arikara gundalia more fuel collection
area Julianna Harvey Biron 30 without
him there is no arrow and every warrior
horse should hear him Stephen Amell
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how we saw here on an island that
you went boom so that's it right game
over the tundra done rights over all
right
good run no my guys are seriously this
is one of the biggest things that has
happened to you guys
mark away may I ask you what was it like
breaking the news that you're going to
send a bomb on an exploding island to
end season fun well and you can imagine
they're all very excited here we're
blowing everybody up to say it was you
know we were really excited about the
spotlight we really wanted to wrap up
all of her story and it felt like the
right way to do it was going back to
where it all started blowing stuff up
what we do here well guys you said the
last five years building to one big
thing what is it how does that feel like
coming to this point now and knowing
where you're going going coded Oh
it's incredibly gratifying we always
said that seeing five would end as a
culmination not just of season five but
of the first five years of the showing
quite frankly the first the last ten
years of Oliver's luck with the you know
the flashbacks of five years of hell so
we're really excited to you know we're
not like rebooting the show in fact
we're going to double down on a lot of
things that I think really resonate with
people in season five that you know the
dark really you know Browns storytelling
but we are going to see a different kind
of Oliver Queen this you know the last
ten years have really changed him
particularly season five and we're
looking forward to telling some very
different kinds of stories with all her
Stephen Oliver's had hit something down
who's been way violent we've been less
violent now we've got a kid how does
being a dad change arrow she's not
tell what you know said this bunch of
times today but my first day on June 6
and you see a little bit in the footage
that you saw it was all with Jack please
William and he and I had got a couple
esteemed together when we was never
really acted together and I was really
legitimately nervous because I didn't
know and not only was he equal to the
task but he exceeded my expectations
he's a wonderful young man and a
terrific actor and I'm loving my scenes
with him but you know to be on episode
to start on episode 116 and to be able
to do fun new stuff as Oliver has been a
real joy so far the see the good funny
now look we can't reveal who does or
does not make it off the animals but one
of the things we do know is this kitten
can freeze back it's not so what we
don't we have like siren how does that
affect you guys knowing that you know
this is a different version of the
character is you guys have sort of grown
apart we have a powerful effective guys
villain on our show we're gonna have to
kick some butt yeah yeah you come in
like a wrecking ball like in the first
killing okay oh yeah like the Miley
Cyrus song we go back shaking enough of
it all right
what's it like business new knowing that
you have you are back and is it like
just stepping back into you know an old
pair jeans and just ready to roll or is
it is a different way okay in the world
change there's they're brand new they
might look distressed
you know me
it's look be honest with you it
absolutely so excited feedback it feels
like I never left
you know it's been home and this is
where family and it's been it's
definitely been pretty easy just getting
back into the swing of things thing the
one thing I will say is interesting the
dynamics between black siren and I'll be
without community see the white other
characters with the Amero whatnot and
four different the different points of
view obviously that she has but it's a
parallel that's exactly opposite to
Laurel or black hiring I guess it
towards how I've been thinking about it
but it's been you know it's good on the
topic of like marries Juliana you have a
new costume yeah so now you have to rest
of you what's the costume and be like on
set because we're just kind of pretty
much constant there's a fire or come you
so I had aa thank you is that when you
put that on you just feel more and more
like a badass and ready to roll oh
absolutely I mean when you put on that
costume you can't help but feel like
hero it transformed how you walk and
transform they stand your posture you
look at yourself differently you know I
three you might sell for the first time
as a hero physically it was just an
internal thing anymore with her
character it was it was really emotional
and a really powerful moment to put it
on for the first time in it and I think
a lot of pride in it and Juliana cry I
said I cried I said it here mark and
windy previous was such a force as a
feeling last season Josh Darwin's
incredible ah
can you give us any insight about what
we may be coming up with statistics well
you know season five was really about
building up this team you know we
introduced you know several new recruits
and by the end of the season you know we
had team arrow 2.0 and a really
formidable you know strong tightening it
way and in thinking about season six and
we were like we want to really double
down on this concept of family and
groups and track down families so
towards that end we started thinking in
terms of a group of villains something
we've never done on the show before so
we were going to have a few familiar
faces like David Nicholas coming back to
reprise his role as Anatole and as we
know from the episode 518 yeah we loved
David he you know being a part of the
business even - and he's coming back
with a literal vengeance and we want to
when I can tell you everything in this
battle but we we are we can tell you
that one of the other members of this
villainous cabal is going to be played
by Michael Emerson
we could not be more excited so we are
really really thrilled and you can also
expect a really cool announcement not
now about the character who's his name
is Richard dragon from the comics who
will also be among our our villain that
we'll be seeing this year so you'll be
seeing a lot of different villains
throughout 15-6 and and more so than
they like Dillon for the week kind of
thing but these are you know like
characters and we'll be seeing really
throughout the season we've never done
that before
also now anyways sometimes we'll get a
lot of questions on you know flashes on
a musical episode arrow is going to
musical education how about doing a mr.
left foot but you guys you guys do have
some pipes last year there's a stirring
rendition and hamilkar this is my first
year hosting this and I want to I want
to top that so is there something we can
do to maybe do that do you guys want
that can we uh can we pretend like it's
Monday you can oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
there's three candles in your three
copies your first day whoa right let's
line up at the microphone
how much girl the counts together are
all seriously maybe my name is Arielle
and my question is a vigilante someone
we know possibly to Tommy Merlyn oh we
can we trying to get Collin back on the
show he's busy on Chicago med for sure I
know we're big believers that if you
have a mystery like some type of food on
it or in the case of vigilante who is it
it's a week really unsatisfying if the
answer to the mystery is yes some person
you've never seen before so you can
probably expect that whoever's behind
that mask underneath that mask is a face
that is familiar to you
hi hi hi my name is Nikki and how did
you Chan
I came to make fun moving you love you
guys and I mean it was obviously a lot
of traumatic moments that happened Reza
season and through each of you how did
those shake your character was there a
specific moment that got to adapt to an
end
actor you mean throughout all of the
seasons are just a substantive past
series is going to go down the line
riggan I'd have to say working at cities
city hall with lands I think that that
moment of of taking that turn for Renee
is a big step in his evolution at tons
of changing his life and making a step
forward and you know trying to do the
right leg I think I me in terms of like
moments of trauma that was sort of what
caused diet to get her powers and it
comes from pain and it comes from anger
and so that moment where she lost her
love transformed her and it was
something that her her biggest her most
painful thing gave her her greatest
strength and I think that that that
happens in life sometimes as well right
for all of them so yeah
I think for bark firing identical things
that potentially learn more about but
having for that last season there
certainly is a relationship with with
Quentin has has been an important thing
to her in the pivotal moment and what
path it leads her down I think we'll see
more ax but I definitely think that
something in her world or to that world
that will be explored what what I didn't
like being check to the ground and
waterboarding has burned and stabbed
from there but I grew I really liked
would be sort of downwards dark spiral
and helix with a friend of mine control
and we did an amazing job
yeah I feel like lifting grew in math
like of a table would what she thought
she might have you know gotten sucked
into or addicted to down the spiral we
can tell you Emily he is coming back I
just want a piece of this cake
kind of distracted over the last stop
you Robin
I don't you know anytime we can change
up the mentor-student aspect of me and
Oliver's relationship is always fun
every time you can kind of kind of
giggle advice I was like this moment so
I think in the beginning of season when
did was in jail and call usually paying
a penance and Oliver was like I thought
what a power woman stable doing all are
doing Diggle Oh put on the helmet
I like anytime we gotta get reverses a
little bit over the S okay
when Oliver becomes to go zoom into our
life oh I feel like feel as the last
five seasons so many traumatic and
teachable moments and this really
definitely fit honed on through that
growth part and kind of used those
tragic events of catalytic catapult her
in two different areas but specifically
in this season I think when when she
started you know blackmailing people in
the office and using people's kids
against them and being kind of you know
the evil and stuff I think the fact was
in an eye-opening thanks for her and a
lesson into who and what's not to maybe
be in the future
[Laughter]
Curtis v-belt lemming-like
got a bite for dinner and then divorced
before you got
Micra graphite at least in food the drop
zone ah but you know he had a lot of
moments last year even if of commedia is
kind of you know attack or you know
Renee kind of pushing of the lean in to
attack you know I think the thing occurs
takes from that you know every situation
is thrown out of the big thing stronger
it makes me want to try by harder and I
think that's definitely something that
really pushed or advantage disease and
let those dramatic moments pushing will
be a better hero and a better advocate
of pain hey guys my name is David and
I'm from San Diego first of all for some
reason my girl Aurora love you Steven
loves you more David my question is for
Echo real quick cities in danger of
being holds the suit up
how you get the Braves on sofa
it's a question to be woman happy people
deserve an answer smart I like to say an
answer forget actually he's a metahuman
guy is that's a superpower or superpower
ever Chris I'll bring my hair oh come on
no that one I want to survive dude I
like to say my attendant that there's
like a virgin ethos out there it's my
turn I got you
so okay good luck
[Applause]
how are you doing fellas
hope you have a great time today my name
is Duncan MacLeod of the clan MacLeod I
would argument on you are you doing a
voice or is this real I don't know what
that's the point
what if I don't know anyone can be
malicious and I was wondering if any of
the cosmic we had any entertaining
informations of accents to share with
the world
yeah arching is a bigger energy no
algorithm is like my karma shine is the
question
[Music]
Wow Wow
very good all right hello my name is
Andres Avila I'm from here and my
Pantera comic-con I've ever asked the
question of for whoa somebody my
question for Stephen I really know I
know that you really want to do with
supernatural crossover with air how
would I happen although I love how
people ask me like random questions that
like I can only answer in the
affirmative and I take that as like
Stephen Amell demands probably know it's
really not to work unless I can be like
a weird for Justin and Jerry like hey
guys is your steak full monotone
delivery look right down the barrel of
the camera just be an awful awful awful
big player on the show ah that'd be
tremendous I would do in a heartbeat see
what you do it in your arrow voice
though
you